On fait la peau a Cyril : épisode 4
Aujourd'hui je fais ma 4eme séance de dé-tatouage au laser : Pour essayer de faire partir Cyril Hanouna sur mes fesses
Pour ceux qui n'ont pas suivi les épisodes précédents, je vous propose un petit résumé
il y'a maintenant presque 10 mois de ça, j'ai eu l'idée de vous faire une vidéo sur le tatouage et je me suis dit que
le mieux c'était quand même de la faire dans les conditions du réel donc je suis allé me faire tatouer et je vous ai expliqué
les pourquoi du comment du tatouage
suite à ça je me suis retrouvé avec cyril hanouna tatoué sur le cul
et je me suis dit que c'était une bonne idée de vous faire une vidéo sur le détatouage
donc j'ai pris rendez-vous dans un centre de laser qui était la technique était le plus adapté à mon cas
et j'ai fait un certain nombre de séances. Voilà, au départ le médecin m'a dit on part sur six séances
les séances s'enchaînent avec deux mois d'intervalle entre chaque et il s'avère aujourd'hui
mon tatouage qui au départ ressembler à ça
Et bah maintenant il ressemble à ça
c'est à dire que, bon, le résultat est pour l'instant assez discret
aujourd'hui voilà me parti pour la quatrième séance sur six donc. Enfin a priori
et c'est vrai que j'y vais avec une petite appréhension puisque comme on vient de le voir c'est pas très probant pour le moment
la dernière fois le médecin m'a dit qu'il allait changer de longueur d'onde puisque le laser c'est des longueurs d'onde qui correspondent à des couleurs
donc là aujourd'hui il va tenter autre chose après avoir progressivement augmenter la puissance
et donc la douleur...
Pour le moment le médecin il reste à fait confiants donc moi aussi parce que c'est lui professionnel après tout
mais quand je vous ai croisé dans des conventions par exemple ou dans la rue
la première question que vous me posez c'est : "Alors ça en est où ?" et la deuxième question qui vient immédiatement après quand je vous explique que
ça on est pas... Hein...
c'est : "Est-ce que tu commences pas un flipper ?"
non je commence pas à flipper mais je vais quand même me posez la question aujourd'hui savoir si il est vraiment toujours aussi confiant et
si il envisage pas éventuellement que ça pourrait prendre plus de temps que prévu
donc je vous tiens au courant après la séance.
Comme d'habitude je vous emmène avec moi c'est parti
Oui avant je vais passer chez le coiffeur parce que c'est important d'être présentable dans ces conditions... Y'a un minimum
Comme vous pouvez voir le coiffeur c'est fait donc maintenant j'ai plus qu'à il y aller
Ça fait comme d'hab
Voilà c'est fini, alors comme vous l'avez vue : bah ça fait encore plus mal que les fois précédentes
et ça c'était un petit peu attendu. Je vais vous expliquer ça après et puis surtout j'ai
eu une moyen bonne nouvelle, on va dire. Je rentre chez moi, je me pose et je vous explique tout ça
Alors donc
comme prévu ça fait plus mal que d'habitude il n'a pas fait une longueur d'onde différente
contrairement ce qu'il m'a dit la dernière fois, Il a juste élargi le faisceau, c'est à dire que c'était plus large, ça tapait plus large
sur ma peau que les fois précédentes
donc ça fait un peu plus mal et donc comme prévu je lui ai posé la question de savoir s'il était toujours
aussi confiant et là j'ai eu une bonne nouvelle et une mauvaise nouvelle. La bonne nouvelle c'est que oui il est toujours aussi confiant
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est qui m'a avoué que
vraisemblablement six séances ça ne suffira pas et qui tapait plutôt sur
minimum 10
C'est à dire que quatre séances de plus avec deux mois d'intervalle entre chaque on est parti sur huit mois de plus
et sur quatre séances où ça va bien piquer, parce-que a priori j'imagine qu'il va continuer à
booster un petit peu le truc à chaque fois. Pour répondre à la question que vous me posez souvent, est-ce que je commence à flipper ?
Non parce qu'après tout c'est sur ma fesse, et ma fesse on la voit pas tous les quatre matins.
Pas tout le monde en tout cas...
et puis surtout si ça marche pas j'essaierai d'autres moyens, au pire je le ferai à recouvrir, c'est pas forcément un truc que j'avais prévu
d'avoir un tatouage sur le cul, mais bon, au pire...
Je peux m'en sortir.
Et concernant la deuxième question, à savoir, est ce que je regrette ? Parce que oui la question se pose, effectivement
Ben non je regrette pas, parce qu'en fait si j'avais fait la vidéo en vous disant
"Voilà, un tatouage ça se passe comme ça, le laser ça se passe comme ça, on fait six séances et puis après c'est terminé"
Bah, j'aurais menti en fait. Là le double avantage c'est que 1) je suis vraiment très bien placé pour vous dire que ça fait très mal
et puis surtout vous pouvez voir que ça se passe pas aussi bien que prévu
à chaque fois et que parfois il faut rajouter des séances donc
pédagogiquement il ya un vrai intérêt au fait de tester vraiment sur moi même, je peux vraiment vous dire
"Voilà comment ça se passe, voilà comment c'est prévu que ça se passe et voilà comment ça se passe en réalité" donc moralité, bah
réfléchissez peut-être un tout petit peu avant de vous faire un tatouage. Et puis bon, parce que vous êtes des petits curieux et que vous voulez voir
de vos propres yeux ce qui se passe, donc voilà à quoi ça ressemble: là c'est le tatouage
quelques heures après la séance de laser
là c'est le tatouage
le lendemain et là c'est le tatouage
deux jours après
voilà comme vous l'avez compris on est partis pour quelques mois supplémentaires, je sais pas si je vous ferai des vidéos à chaque fois
dites moi dans les commentaires si ça vous intéresse ou pas, en attendant on se retrouve très vite pour une prochaine vidéo
d'ici là, bah comme le veut la coutume, mettez vous bien et surtout,
portez vous bien !